Hello everyone, welcome to Nutritional 101.
This supplement is called Protein Zime, and I personally take this protein powder.
So why do I take Protein Zime?
Well, because it keeps all of your systems active, functioning, and produces anti-aging
and antioxidant effects, it works as a protein supplement, anti-digestive, and Zime.
So it supports your digestion and absorption of proteins.
It supports your intestinal, immune function, and overall immune system.
It promotes healthy nutrition, absorption, and assimilation.
It consists of an organic vegan protein blend, seed blend, vegetable blend, and includes
both a pre and probiotic.
So the ingredients are listed here at the bottom, and includes a superfood blend as well.
This is a plant-based protein, and it comes in either chocolate or vanilla.
This supplement facts are found here, which includes everything that is in it that I
just listed in the previous slide, and you can visit connoorsclinic.com to order your
plant-based protein today.
Thank you.